if you own properties that are a least
hold property for instance an apartment
okay all apartments in England are leas
hold that means you own the property but
you don't own the land or the grounds on
the property then you're going to be
pretty happy because the King has just
in a speech in fact in England and Wales
they are going to
abolish all leas hold houses all
together so there will not be any new
leas hold hous is built in England and
Wales so what does that mean exactly
well I'm going to explain in this video
what it means it's very complicated so
I'm I've done a lot of reading I've done
a lot of research I've read the uh the
bill I've um watched the speech and in
this video I'm going to be talking about
what's going to be happening why it's
happening and how it's going to affect
you as a property investor so first let
me just explain if you don't know
anything about this let me explain what
a least whole property is so if you buy
a house and it's leasehold that means
that you're buying the house but you you
don't own the land that the house sits
on so if you're buying a property and
it's a lease hold property the very
first question that you need to ask is
well how long is the lease if the long
if the lease is long let's say it's a
100 years then you're pretty okay if the
lease is short like 10 years or 20 years
the lease won't outlive you that means
at the end of the lease unless you've
paid to renew the lease then You'
effectively lose the house because you
don't own the land that the house sits
on so you have to give it back to the
freeh holder so there's massive changes
to to to this right now also when you're
scrolling up properties on right move
and and you suddenly see a house and
it's like oh my gosh they're all selling
for 300,000 but this one selling for
£200,000 why is it so cheap and then
you'll see ah it's a leasehold house
well what does that mean exactly well it
means the same thing it means that
you're buying the house but you're not
buying the land so now it's okay well
how do value it's more difficult what
happens if the lease is short if there's
only 50 60 years left on the lease if
it's any less than 80 years that's going
to be you're going to be probably buying
it 30% at least below market value but
it's not really below market value it's
cheap because the lease is short so this
is all changing for houses it's going to
be abolished alog together moving
forward no more new houses that are
built the developer can't build it as
aold it's banned if it's an apartment if
you own an apartment like I do I own
many apartments and it's leasehold
they're not Banning leasehold properties
but they are changing many aspects to it
so let me talk a little bit about some
of the things that have put me off
buying Apartments the first thing that's
put me off buying Apartments is
Apartments often have restrictions like
head lease restrictions so the
Freeholder will say you can't do this
you can't rent out like this and they'll
have a lot of say over the management of
the property so that's that that that's
the first thing that slightly annoys me
about Flats if I'm buying a flat think
okay the free holder could be a jerk and
the management company and it could be
difficult and they can be awkward so
that's the first thing the second thing
is the cost I'm having to pay ground
rent to the freeh holder every year I'm
also having to pay service charge what's
the difference between ground rent and
service charge so ground rent is a is is
an amount of money that you have to pay
to the Freeholder just for being the
Freeholder it's just rent because you
don't own the land so you're renting the
land but the service charge so if you
own an apartment for
example what what what about if there's
a lift in the apartment block who's
going to pay for the running of that
lift is the person is the free holder
going to pay for it because he owns the
apartment block but you just own the
apartment like all the communal spaces
is not owned by the apartment owners
right so who pays for the the running of
the lift and the answer is the people
that own the apartments do because they
pay a service charge who pays for the
cleaners who pays for the P for the
paint on the
communal um areas every every every
couple of years and there has to be a
paint job who pays for that it's the
service charge so if you in an apartment
not only do you have often jerks as
management the management company with
covenants and restrictions who make it
difficult and R and run the show but
also you've got to pay rent to them and
you've got service charge and the
service charge can change I've had this
right and also you have no control over
how much it is and exactly how it's
being used so it's very difficult to
work out your return on investment
because if your return on investment if
you're buying a house freeold house you
own the house you own the land you own
everything no Freeholder no one to
answer to no um rent to pay because you
own everything no service charges cuz
you own everything so you you're in
control of how much you pay if if that's
the case it's very easy to work work out
what your return on investment is going
to be because you can say my rent's this
right this is how much my costs are
going to be this is this is this but
when you have no control it's it's
difficult to work it out and it's also
something that will often uh kill your
return on investment as well because
it's like oh wow the service charge is
so high the ground went so high so these
are things that really put me off buying
Apartments because they're leas hold I'm
not saying I've never done it I do own
some apartments on sold but it's been a
pain the fourth thing which is a huge
thing is the fact that you don't
actually own the the the land and that
means that you're renting it and you
have a lease and an amount of time that
you rent it for and you have to renew
that lease I just had to renew a lease I
paid um
£22,000 I to pay to renew my lease
before it dropped below the 80 80e
threshold where it suddenly loses loads
of value so if you own a property and
having to renew the lease and knowing
that that property when you pass down to
your kids they're going to have to at
some point renew the lease and pay a
load of money and it's really expensive
extending the lease on a leasehold
property so that's that's a real killer
and and the final thing is that it can
take forever to sell I had a situation
where I was trying to sell one of my
crappy leas hold Apartments which had
not gone up in value for like 10 years
which is another horrible thing about
apartments they often don't go up in
value I was selling this this this
department and it took forever to sell
because I needed certain information
from the Freeholder and the Freeholder
was holding on to the information not
freely and I was struggling to get
information so uh it took it took took
about four five months to sell and I
wanted the money quite quickly I was
selling it in in lockdown uh sold that
for a loss irritating but anyway what
are the changes so houses aren't going
to be leasehold anymore you can't build
any leasehold houses but apartments in
England they're not Banning leasehold
they're they're not going to ban it I
think there in Scotland they did in
Scotland that there is no such thing as
leasehold I don't I don't think there's
any leasehold properties in Scotland
certainly if you buy an apartment you'll
be buying the apartment it's not Le I
think it makes sense because the
communal areas I kind of get it but
they're changing the rules massively so
this is what they're saying the king
announced uh and this isn't law yet but
this is very very likely to come in uh
probably um you know first part of next
year so the first thing is they're
saying that ground rent they're going to
make zero so you don't have to pay any
ground rent well that's huge service
charge they're bringing down they're
bringing accountability so it's you have
more control over what's happening uh
more transparency more accountability
over where the money's going uh more
control over things like the head leas
restrictions so that you have more say
in things but massively they're reducing
the cost uh dramatically by how much it
costs to extend the lease so some case
studies that I've looked at they talk
it's it's like almost half the amount to
extend it so I've now got some some
apartments now that I was looking to
extend a couple of months ago they
flagged up and I probably need to extend
the lease soon now I think I might hold
off a few months because because of
these new changes and I might save a
load of money also they're saying that
now when you extend the lease you pay to
extend it not only is it going to be
cheaper but instead of extending it for
90 years when you extend it they're
going to extend for
990 years which is just ridiculous if
you've got a if you've got a leale of
property but you've You' you've you've
got the lease for 990 years you've got
control youve got flexibility you're
paying no ground rent and the service
charge that you are paying um you can
see exactly where it's going and I mean
it it's almost as good as freeold so if
you're a leas hold property owner I
think this is really really really good
news I also think here's my prediction
of how it's going to PO potentially
affect the property market so I told you
earlier that Apartments just didn't go
up in value they haven't gone up in
value for many many years I mean you can
look back um in the '90s they did my
rationale behind that I genuinely think
that the series
friends which was worldwide famous and
obviously very good very popular they
lived in an apartment right in New York
and I think that friends in the '90s
kind of made it cool to live in an
apartment because in the '90s after
apartments rocketed in in value look at
look at the uh even compared to houses
like they became really
fashionable and then when we had the
crash 2008 crash Apartments crashed
houses crashed Apartments just didn't
really recover I mean as I mentioned I
so I sold um I bought an apartment in
wara I can't remember the exact figures
but for around about 80 grand in 2010
kind of time and then in lockdown in
2020 when I needed a little bit of cash
and did a cash injection to the business
I was like man I'm selling some of these
apartments cuz they're horrible but some
of the Apartments I sold them for a loss
like I bought them for I earn them
unincumbered so I didn't have mortgages
on them thank God otherwise there' have
been negative equity but I bought them
for like 80 grand and ended up selling
them for like 65 70 grand and I was
thinking how in 10 years have houses
doubled and apartments gone down like
what's happening and I think it's
because they became unfashionable mainly
because of how difficult it was having a
free holder you know the service I've
been teaching against buying apartments
and saying don't do it it's a nightmare
with the free holders and the Serv
charges and the ground rent having to
extend the lead like it's quite I mean
unless you re know what you're doing but
if you don't re know what you're doing
it's much safer and easier and simple
just buy a house and rent it out but I
think that these new changes are going
to make it probably more popular to buy
Apartments again and hopefully if the
freeholders lacks off a little bit
potentially on Short Stay lets maybe I'm
getting a bit a bit ahead of myself
right now but you know Apartments work
really well as service accommodation on
short St lexs and if you pay no ground
rent and you've got 990e lease yeah it
could be quite exciting maybe we'll see
Apartments suddenly go up in value so if
you're an apartment owner in in England
you know it's it's probably pretty good
news I'm going to leave a link in the
description with um two things firstly
I'm going to leave a link in the
description where I've got my
information which came straight As a
result of The King's Speech uh it's page
number 45 if you want to read in a bit
more detail and it will summarize what
I've just said uh and then number two is
I'm going to put a link for my property
investors crash Cod so it's £1 to get a
ticket and we can spend the day together
finding apartments finding houses and um
and absolutely finding the best property
Investments as we enter into 2024